[Musique]
ce qu'attendent les français c'est un
gouvernement de vérité de courage qui
réforme en profondeur le système des
retraites que je pense que les français
ont annoncé des grèves d'être pris en
tenaille entre d'un côté un gouvernement
qui a eu une mauvaise méthode pour
préparer cette réforme et de l'autre
parfois quelques grévistes et syndicats
jusqu'au boutiste et je crois que
finalement aujourd'hui les français ont
la double peine c'est à dire qu'ils ont
les grèves n'ont pas la paix sociale et
en même temps ils n'auront pas cette
réforme des retraites la seule réforme
possible la seule
c'est une réforme qui dit tout à la fois
la vérité aux français parce qu'il nous
faut garantir le financement des
retraites en travaillant un peu plus
d'une part et deuxièmement en
rétablissant un idéal de justice
attendez vous rendez compte que sur 325
millions d'euros pas d'étude d'impact
pas des vaillants sont financières pas
de chiffres sur la table c'est pas
possible
n'ont ils rien sur le financement ya
rien y rien dans le texte est rien
d'autant plus que ce texte il est
tellement pas complet que quand on veut
rentrer dans les détails on est renvoyé
à des ordonnances c'est à dire à des des
textes pris par le gouvernement lui-même
ratifier un jour par le par le parlement
donc c'est très obscur ses traits c'est
très opaque faire examiner un texte à
trous un véritable gruyère
c'est la bleue républicain marche qui
par sa stratégie du coucou vient de
manger dans monte ni parce qu'elles
considèrent que nos candidats sont les
meilleurs et parce qu'elle n'a pas le
personnel politique local pour pouvoir
créer des listes en tant que tel c'est
la république à mende ce qu'il faut
poser cette question là nous on soutient
des candidats les républicains nous
avons des maires sortants dans des
grandes villes je pense à toulouse des
maires comme à bordeaux dans d'autres
villes également bien tous et merlin ils
sont soutenus par la république est
parce qu ils sont républicains ils sont
dans notre famille politique que ensuite
la république un marché fasse le choix
de soutenir deux candidats c'est leur
problème c'est la responsabilité
on voit bien qu'ils éprouvent les plus
grandes difficultés à l'implantation
locale c'est pas dans leur adn on voit
bien aujourd'hui que le vrai problème
partis la république en marche et que
tout tient au tour d'emmanuel mâcon
qu'il n'a aucun ancrage et que
aujourd'hui leur objectif évidemment
c'est de faire de l'entrisme dans les
listes actuelles et d'essayer de
s'implanter localement
sauf qu'ils se rendent compte qu'on a
des sortants qui ont plutôt un bon bilan
qui ont une bonne gestion
[Musique]